yeah it's like that quote
that's I think it says something like um
behind every great man is an even better
woman or something Have you heard that
one yeah oh yeah that's the most
[__] quote um I don't think it
should be even better but I think great
women should be there instead it kind of
oh just the woman that cares yeah yeah
this is woman Beyond every man is this
woman
Elon Musk needed a woman to get to where
he's at Richmond get to where they're
going regardless of whether or not they
have a guy doing doggy dog for sure it's
like I mean like the guys that aren't
going somewhere they're gonna go
somewhere whether or not you're there
it's just like women just like to take
credit for doing nothing